hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of Thrones if you like to watch
the full episode head over to
youtube.com slash gamespot please beware
of spoilers alright let's talk about
some hound we've been big big fans of
the gravedigger theory from the books
and also the cliq game ball theory we've
got extended videos on like exactly
breaking those down and what like all
the evidence for and against but
basically gravedigger theory is that
Brienne of Tarth travels took place
called the quiet I'll meets a bunch of
peace Knicks basically monks penitent
men and sees a man who could be the
hound sees the hounds horse and talk to
the guy who says no the Hound is dead
the persona of the Hound is dead Sandor
Clegane is still alive so it's a
gravedigger ankle again bowl is that the
Hound is going to represent the faith
and the mountain will represent the
crown in a battle by combat yeah by
combat for Cersei Lannister is life so
it seems like all these are kind of like
all these pieces are falling into place
this might actually happen this season
finally finally now we've got a hound
back but I think it's quite interesting
that there's some some slight
differences between how it's gone down
in the show compared to how the events
have kind of been seeded in the book so
I thought for example the ian mcshane
would play the elder brother who is like
this really pious man and leader of the
playa but he didn't he played septum
air-balled who is as he basically he's a
wandering Septon who's been wandering
for about 40 years and he leads Brienne
and co2 the quiet I'll he's not the
leader of him so I thought I was quite
interesting I guess it's just for ease
of time that they cut the older brother
right and I mean if you've gone actor
like ian mcshane you I capitalize on
that yeah I mean one Episode one death
but whatever um also like the fact my
hound is he's if the wood shop instead
of the gravedigger because that makes
more logical sense yeah it's kind of
like it see matically it's a little more
lighter like a shows where he could have
gone if he's still if he's digging
graves it come on might make the
audience feel like he's still kind of a
grim dude whereas when he's coughing
would def enough a gating he needed a
task that would like maintain his
strength as well
yeah so like didn't grave keep my steps
yeah as if he was just if he's a chef
when he goes up against the mountain
wenke game ball happens you'd be like oh
I'll chop you all wasted away I thought
was interesting is the conversation
between Mara bald and the hound they cut
this amazing speech that was in the book
where they talk about men who abandon
armies although I think that's quite
symbolic as well yeah because we see in
the North that John is completely
failing to raise a big army and the army
that he has we saw them fighting
infighting yeah um so that could be you
know those guys aren't maybe they don't
cut it maybe they will found himself
abandoned the Lannisters yeah exactly
but also what we have is marable talking
about when he was a warrior and he cut
the throat of a young man a boy while
his mother looked on and was sad and
crying says like her screams horn my
dreams which is quite like it's such
strong parallels to Catelyn Stark who
watched his Rob dies and then she has
her own throat cut yeah so I mean also
what I quite liked is that talking about
the suffering of like the men on the
front lines and then you get the
parallels from the Glovers talking and
saying no like we're not joining you
because we've suffered enough we've
suffered enough for you is really a
contained arc to kind of reestablish the
hound and kind of because the speech
that septa memorable gives is pretty
much the most heinous thing you can do
in any universe that he's killed a child
in front of the mother and Hound is
probably at that point thinking this
dude's a real bad dude but he's like
he's got the peace thing going on people
like look up to him and he's building
something for the future maybe he's
thinking about what he's done and how he
could potentially do the same thing but
then obviously over the course of you
know those the events that happen it's
kind of like actually I think i'ma dude
that likes to kill people because you
know all my would be friends are now
dead so I'm gonna yeah dude is just
being peaceful guarantee you it doesn't
yeah in the end it doesn't in the end
the Hound feels like he was right
because you know Mara bald was trying to
present something else and how did kind
of resist it it was always talking about
how you know peace never worked for him
or anything like that and in the end
he's proven correct because you know all
the peaceniks are dead and he's alive
he's got job to do now save chopping
wood yep I'm but also what's interesting
is when Marable is talking about the the
Boise killed it's quite interesting that
like some people on line of thinking was
he part of the the push to kill all of
Rob Robert Baratheon's bastards which
could be an interesting one I don't know
if I was really confirmed we don't
really know where he's been yeah but
also to support the scene is that the
Brotherhood without banners come and
they are really quite different like
obviously they they would terrorize like
the Lannisters in the phrase but to
attack a peaceful kind of colony says
something I think about their leadership
so if beric Dondarrion is still in
charge I can't see that but we're going
into book theory territory now which his
Lady Stoneheart so we haven't read the
books probably good idea to step back
now the Lady Stoneheart as a name that's
been bandied around for the end of this
season the read you know the reanimated
corpse essentially of Catelyn Stark who
is full of vengeance and she takes
control of the Brotherhood without
banners and basically just like they go
ham yeah they just started killing
mercilessly wanton killing there is a
couple of connections between the
Brotherhood without banners beric
Dondarrion and what we see there's seven
songs the Hound because the Septon says
to the hand the gods not finished with
you and when the town was their prisoner
yeah beric Dondarrion said the same
thing to out god kill her the plone for
you or something like that yeah and
obviously the Brotherhood say things
like you know for the night is dark and
full of terrors so maybe like the Lord
of lights magic has brought Catlin back
and that's why they keep saying that and
that's more reinforced i guess but also
catlins calling card is hanging people
so oh well Lady Stoneheart school yeah
hanging people and so obviously ian
mcshane at the end yep they're hanging
game listen this the season has been
real good like good hang some good
hanging people ollie excellent proper so
where do we think I mean with all this
in mind I know this season people have
been managing to travel like you know oh
you know they could be right the south
of the country than be up north of the
wall in like a day does he have time to
go deal with the Brotherhood and then
still make it back to King's Landing I
mean I think the time frame
is Circe's trial by combat right like
she's hinted that it's only a few days
away but other stuff the faith is going
through it might be rescheduled like
rain check for that year and the quiet
Isle isn't really it's not exactly it's
not not off it's fairly south ish so in
theory this time yeah I mean by the lady
stoneheart thing I think maybe as much
as I would love that are they gonna kind
of suffer with bringing too many people
back we know the Thoris of Maya so the
guy that plays him like someone party's
website yes he's definitely confirmed to
come back in season six and Game of
Thrones so we know he's gonna make a
return but like I don't know if it makes
sense to bring Lady Stoneheart back at
this point I think I think she's gonna
be a key plot point of whatever they do
in the future not right now maybe at the
end of the season we see like a picture
of Kalin stars face or something they'll
just like the Jon Snow yeah the eyes
opening or something like that or like
just her appearing from the shadows and
then that's what's explored going
forward I think for the Hound to deal
with all that stuff it be too much to
ask you so much and like you said like
bringing back multiple characters from
from death in one season might be a bit
too much like people are still kind of
dealing with what the implications of
jon snow coming back means he's changed
as a character to bring that Catlin back
and have her drastically shift in the
way she was you know it would be really
difficult to reconcile all these kind of
moving gears together so I think that
the whole Lady Stoneheart think needs to
be its own focus later on yeah I think
one other ones is really what you said
about John was that if he's been brought
back to life he doesn't seem to have
that much of a personality change he's
still the moody kind of I mean than what
there was one episode was like oh my
watch is over mm-hmm but then like he's
not going around killing everyone
cuddling innocent whereas it's gonna be
difficult for show viewers to kind of
appreciate that if Lady Stoneheart comes
back and she's a complete vengeful [ __ ]
at the same time I mean Kalin stark did
see all her children her pregnant door
in law or her loyal men and her family
killed before she then murdered a young
girl
so I mean I could appreciate that John
was killed by his friends yeah but
Catlin saw her whole family and lineage
killed and she at that point what shades
wishes yeah yeah so I mean I can
appreciate if kathy liebert herbs than
John it's like a level of understanding
as well to it like Kathleen her death
was unexpected almost it was a trap
whereas Jon Snow I mean he kind of had
the feeling that something was going on
and almost you could imagine him
understanding why he was killed like you
know that was always a point of you know
conflict between himself and Ollie and
the rest of the you know the Nights
Watch that were on the other side so
when it finally happened you imagine
that he knew why that happened which
kind of grounded him somewhat so when he
came back there wasn't this like you
know ? over what happened or like this
kind of burning rage to get a vengeance
for it in the moment he came back it was
almost like he understood what happened
and he knew that what was going to
happen next was those people were gonna
die and he took care of it so I like all
that stuff was resolved straightaway
worse for Caitlyn she comes back all her
kids are dead everyone responsible
scared so she's got the reason to be no
vengeful well I find interesting is that
um I feel like by bringing so many
characters back by bringing John by
bringing the mountain back by bringing
essentially the Hound back you're kind
of lessening the impact of death in the
show yeah because you know we've had key
characters die before like Ned we've had
Joffrey Tywin who have a rob and they
they I guess they don't have a chance of
coming back yeah where is you know
where'd you draw the line yeah I think
the main implication of this though is
that it's sowing the seeds of Clegane
bowl and Lady Stoneheart happening I
think it's they're sewn too late and
we're not gonna get seen till next
season
you